le jeu transforme le hasard en destinée
la probabilité en chance la raison en
passion
[Musique]
une habitude bien française qui rapporte
gros à l'état tu rentres le 4
et un monopole qui est aujourd'hui
attaqué par les géants du jeu en ligne
mais dans cet univers plane aussi
l'ombre des grands bandits
[Musique]
un mythe sulfureux cologeu celui d'une
activité liée au crime organisé une
salle réputation que le portée par le
cinéma de genre et la littérature dans
ce cliché les gangsters de haut volent
des maisons où l'on joue au poker où les
femmes fatales sont croupières et où
l'on règle ses dettes à l'arme de guerre
ces ingrédients qui font le sel des
polars on les retrouve dans le roman
noir d'un fait divers bien réel
l'affaire du cercle Concorde
quand vous avez un mafieux qui est à 3h
du matin en train de dormir et qui fait
un rêve sublime il rêve d'avoir un
casino pourquoi parce que le casino a
génère de l'argent et B il le blanchit
en même temps
septembre 2006 un cercle de jeu le
Concorde ouvre ses portes en grande
pompe l'endroit se veut brancher des
peoples se sont déplacés le champagne
coule à flot sur les gourous de la com
les journalistes les têtes couronnées
tout s'attirés par le frisson du jeu
rapidement l'établissement s'érige en
temple sacré des flambeurs parisiens et
rafle la mise du poker
chiffre d'affaires de croisière 3
millions d'euros
c'est un Corse qui dirige cet
établissement à la pointe de la mode
sont credo les affaires les mondanités
et les lieux branchés il s'appelle Paul
Lantieri
[Musique]
donc c'est un nom qui n'est pas inconnu
à la fois
du petit milieu
journalistique du milieu politique et
des milieux judiciaires alors pour le
mont Thierry c'est quelqu'un qui est
d'une grande famille de Bonifacio qui
possédait une notamment une boîte de
nuit qui était très connue en Corse
jusqu'à ce qu'elle explose qui
s'appelait l'Amnesia c'était la plus
grande boîte de nuit à ciel ouvert de
France et qui a explosé en l'an 2000 ou
je crois dans mes souvenirs c'est 8
charges de 500 kg
ce que la clientèle ignore c'est que
Paul lantierry traîne derrière lui un
sérieux soucis le patron est mis en
examen pour recel de malfaiteur dans un
triple assassinat survenu à 700 km de là
le 4 avril 2006 cette nuit là Marseille
on rejoue la tragédie criminelle dans un
de ces lieux communs le règlement de
compte au bistrot du coin dans le
quartier de Saint-Just le bar des
Marronniers un commando est aux aguets
devant la télé un cahier des deux de ses
lieutenants n'ont pas pris toutes les
précautions d'usage il tourne le dos à
l'entrée du troquet
je ne sais pas manger
dans ce restaurant trois hommes sont
abattus parmi eux celui que l'on
présente comme l'un des nouveaux cahiers
de la côte Farid Bera ma
[Musique]
Farid berrama la principale victime est
intrus en confirmé de la pègre
marseillese un caïd de cité en pleine
ascension soupçonné d'être un acteur de
premier plan dans la guerre sanglante
opposant maghrébin et Corse pour le
contrôle des machines à sous clandestine
dans la région
[Musique]
pour la police aucun doute la tuerie du
bar des Marronniers est signée de la
Vendée ta Corse mais ce n'est pas tout
un ADN est relevé sur les lieux du crime
et ce n'est pas celui des victimes l'un
des meurtriers s'est blessés une balle à
malencontreusement ricoché un témoin
était au premier loge
c'est surtout que c'était un commando de
la police qui arrive
si on peut commander Corse après ça a
assuré c'était des rafales d'un coup
après je peux vous dire combien mais bon
une trentaine c'est la partie qu'on
blessée
la nuit du crime un homme est admis aux
urgences de la clinique Clairval à
Marseille sous une fausse identité
il s'agit d'ange tout ça fait des Ritchi
une pointure du milieu corse
mais pour se faire opérer en toute
discrétion il téléphone à Paul Lantieri
qui dispose de l'entrejean adéquat et au
nom de la solidarité insulaire
l'antirie lui déniche un chirurgien
Xavier Maunier et journaliste
d'investigation à bakchichinfo il a mené
une enquête documentée sur l'affaire du
cercle Concorde
pas loin de Thierry lui trouve une
clinique en l'occurrence la clinique
Clairval dans le sud de Marseille pour
se faire opérer il se fait opérer sous
un faux non manque de bol tout le monde
est sur écoute donc tout le monde se
fait coffrer à plus ou moins terres mais
tout le monde est identifié sauf que en
tout ça Frédéric chi termine sa cavale
il est coffret et Paul LAN Thierry part
pas en Caval du tout mais il a arrêté
deux semaines après il est libéré par le
juge des détentions et libertés
et le cercle Concorde ouvre en grande
pompe avec beaucoup de people Le Figaro
la qualifiera la soirée d'ouverture de
soirée people de l'année
mais le triple meurtre de Marseille
amène la justice à s'intéresser de plus
près au Cercle Concorde et à son
financement la piste de l'argent mène
les enquêteurs en Suisse sur les comptes
d'un banquier genevois François rouge
entrepreneur atypique dans le monde de
la finance François rouges et l'associé
de Paul Lantieri
yannamel et journaliste au matin
dimanche un hebdo helvet il connaît bien
François rouge il était riche et puis il
voulait d'autres sensations je veux dire
dis maman qu'elle tournait toute seule
j'étais à la tête je suis le patron il
gagnait et gagner beaucoup d'argent il a
voulu faire autre chose notamment il
s'est lancé dans l'immobilier il s'est
lancé dans l'immobilier en Suisse en
rachetant des hôtels de luxe mais c'est
également lancé dans l'immobilier ce qui
est moins connu en France et notamment
en Corse et c'est là qu'il a connu
l'antiry il a sympathique marrant
Jet 7 et puis ils ont sympathisé il
l'invitait en Suisse il faisait la fête
ensemble et puis quand on lui est parlé
du cercle Concorde encore il faut voir
qu'un cercle de jeu ça rapporte beaucoup
d'argent je crois estime à 300000 euros
par mois donc voilà je veux dire c'est
la bonne opération
ministère de l'intérieur donne
l'autorisation donc rouge peut dire
écoutez on m'a donné l'autorisation donc
c'est légal le ministre de l'Intérieur
dit ok pourquoi j'ai douté de quoi que
ce soit je veux dire je suis dans une
opération blanc bleue je mets mon fric
pour gagner plus de fric
[Musique]
c'est un peu l'exemple type quand même
peu fréquent mais qu'on connaît ici en
Corse et dans quelques autres endroits
en France d'une union sacrée si je puis
dire entre le monde du financier
qui peut y impliquer des gens qui ont
tout à fait pignons sur rue et le monde
du banditisme
ce dossier à tiroir est piloté depuis
Marseille par une juridiction
spécialisée dans la délinquance
financière et le crime organisé à ce
jour 18 personnes sont mises en examen
deux sont encore détenus et les chefs de
mise en examen c'est blanchiment bande
organisé
association de malfaiteurs non
justification de ressources des délits
qui à la fois unissent l'aspect
financier blanchiment d'argent
recyclage d'argent noir ou d'argent sale
avec la notion d'association de
malfaiteurs qui démontre que le fond le
contexte général de cette affaire c'est
une entreprise de banditisme en novembre
2007 la police siffle la fin de la
partie de multiples perquisitions sont
menées en France et en Suisse le cercle
est fermé dans la foulée François rouge
appelle alors son associé Paul Lantieri
et le banquier suisse semble
complètement paniqué
c'est la fin du
monde à son simultané ce matin 6h30 ils
étaient chez moi toute la banque ils ont
tout ils ont tout pris énorme opérations
merde le vrai problème c'est qu'ils ont
tout le financement du cercle alors
maintenant il faut que je me débarrasse
de quelque chose
crime organisé jeux et mondanité le
cocktail du cercle Concorde rappelle un
schéma classique de la sociologie
criminelle trouver des outils adaptés
pour pénétrer les plus hautes sphères de
la société
c'est par des structures comme celle-là
que le crime organisé peut s'infiltrer
dans la société civile et la corrompre
quand le cercle dont on parle a été
ouvert le soir de l'ouverture officielle
il y a une réception grandiose regardez
qui était présent
ça il en a pas été question dans la
presse people mais regardez qui était
présent
les personnalités de tous ordres des des
stars des sportifs de haut niveau des
personnalités politiques même des gens
des médias et là c'est pas innocent et
donc par l'intermédiaire de lieu comme
ça où les bandits peuvent se mélanger
avec les gens qui sont les stars
d'aujourd'hui people etc on arrive à les
approcher on arrive à les corrompre et à
ce moment-là comme la société au sommet
les gens sont proches les uns des autres
on arrive aux entreprises on arrive à la
place politique et là on peut en arriver
à la vraie corruption
aujourd'hui Paul Lantieri est en cavale
et l'instruction se poursuit
les mafieux et le jeu c'est savoureux
mais presque anecdotique aujourd'hui en
la matière le vrai boss c'est l'état il
a distribué les cartes aux trois seules
opérateurs autorisés à exploiter
l'industrie du hasard les loteries les
paris sportifs et les jeux à gratter
sont le domaine exclusif de la Française
des jeux les courses hippiques sont le
pré carré du PMU le Paris Mutuel Urbain
les machines à sous et les jeux de table
reviennent au casino et cercle de jeu en
théorie ces trois acteurs historiques
n'ont aucun concurrent et redistribue
60% de leur bénéfices au Trésor public
près de 5 milliards d'euros c'est le
pactole du monopole
une industrie sur laquelle les autorités
opèrent un contrôle très serré un
service de la police judiciaire et même
exclusivement dédié à cette activité on
l'appelle les courts et jeux oui c'est
un des premiers inspecteurs des jeux qui
était commissaire spécial du casino donc
un des premiers contrôleurs de la
réglementation des jeux dans les casinos
nous sommes dans une législation
d'exception
l'ensemble de la pratique des jeux de
hasard est interdite sauf ceux qui sont
autorisés c'est-à-dire par les textes la
ligne directrice permanente et le
contrôle la surveillance de la sincérité
de la régularité des jeux dans les
casinos dans les cercles de jeux dans
les hippodromes et en matière de course
hippiques et de paris hippiques et
également en matière de jeu sur Internet
faisant appel aux nouvelles technologies
Deauville dans le Calvados fameuse pour
ses planches et son prestigieux casino
Jean-Marie moduech dispose de son propre
badge et connaît tous les codes d'accès
de la maison il est ici comme chez lui
pourtant ce n'est pas un manager de
l'établissement faux air d'inspecteur
d'Eric mais vrais policiers il est le
patron des courses et jeux en
Basse-Normandie
[Musique]
dans le casino les rouleaux des machines
à sous tournent déjà depuis 10 heures du
matin elles occupent l'espace le plus
important de l'établissement quant aux
jeux traditionnels comme la roulette et
les jeux de cartes ils ouvrent dans
l'après-midi
[Applaudissements]
avons l'ouverture des Jeux Jean-Marie
vérifie les enquêtes c'est à dire le
montant total en jetons à chacune des
tables et les formalités ne sont pas
terminées après les jetons Jean-Marie
passe au cartes à jouer il faut vérifier
les paquets neufs qui sont mises en
circulation
on a d'abord visé le bon de commande des
cartes
donc les casinos sont tenus de se
fournir
auprès de fournisseurs à louer
et quand dans les cartes reviennent on
les intègre et
celles qui sont usagées on doit donc
procéder à leur destruction
pour qu'elle ne puisse plus resservir et
pas se retrouver
dans des mains
ce serait pas innocentes
voici l'abattoir pour vieux paquet pas
de pitié pour les cartes usagées
à présent rien ne va plus c'est l'heure
de passer à table
[Musique]
chaque semaine un policier du service
passe au moins une fois dans ce casino
les incidents y sont rarissimes mais en
2006 la direction insoupçonné un cas de
baronnage c'est-à-dire une entente entre
un croupier et un joueur afin d'arnaquer
le casino sur un seul coup le client
mise 200 euros qui lui en rapport 200000
à donner donc les
les jetons et les plaques
du paiement et c'est uniquement au
moment où
le Client a voulu aller en caisse
opérer le change que là il s'est vu
refuser cette cette opération parce
qu'entre temps donc le casino avait
demandé un contrôle vidéo et ils se sont
perçus que il y avait notamment au
moment du mélange
les procédures n'avait pas été
respectées on a donc le placé dans la
soirée en garde à vue donc le croupier
et le
[Musique]
dans un casino est un jeu dangereux
Stéphane Vanel est un artiste qui
travaille à Las Vegas c'est l'un des
meilleurs manipulateurs de cartes au
monde quand une main se termine toi
généralement ce qui se passe c'est que
les cartes elles sont retournées vers le
haut c'est vrai donc tu vois tu as si
par exemple là tu vois rapidement tu
peux voir que les autres ils sont au
dessus c'est énorme pour toi j'imagine
pour le mettre pour rien
que claque je coupe je fais comme dans
les casinos on coupe on mélange tac ça
c'est ce qui ferait je te le fais en
plus comme si vraiment j'étais en train
de rater j'étais un mec qui mélange pas
bien
tu peux faire ce que tu veux mais tu
vois regarde la boum tu récupères les
quatre races
je te le fais disparaître
un bon tricheur si tu mets à l'intérieur
du paquet à l'as de carreau toi il peut
mélanger coupé et cetera tu vois
ça c'est sûr toi si tu récupères par
exemple le 3 de carreaux tu fais
tout de suite le bon tricheur tu vois il
faut récupérer son as
coup d'œil et dextérité au service d'une
illusion quasi parfaite la finalité pour
le donneur tricheur et de distribuer des
cartes déjà choisies dont il a repéré
les positions dans le paquet
techniquement il faut avant tout savoir
simuler le mélange
quand je mélange
tu vois je pousse les cartes donc tu
vois tu peux voir ça et au dernier
moment quand j'approche tu vois je fais
un petit break ici tu vois ce que c'est
donc tu les fais glisser les unes entre
les autres quand je reprends le break et
je pousse tu vois quand je reprends
pivoter des cartes et je les ressors et
après je coupe et je fais un faux mais
selon une estimation une trentaine de
manipulateurs dans le monde exerce leur
don à des fins frauduleuses rien qu'une
poignée de tricheurs d'élite
dans l'affaire de baronnage aux barrière
le tribunal a finalement relaxé le
croupier et le joueur
l'ancienne employé est aujourd'hui
joueur professionnel de poker le casino
a été contraint de payer les 200.000
euros de gains
[Musique]
à une centaine de kilomètres de
Deauville Luc-sur-Mer une petite station
balnéaire idéalement située les pieds
dans l'eau c'est le casino et s'il se
trouve un casino dans le coin Jean-Marie
n'est jamais bien loin cet après-midi il
doit justement rencontrer deux apprentis
croupiers
tu vas bien
le petit jeune s'endort
cours de mélange des cartes mais ici
attention pas question de faire semblant
à peu près égale
c'est maintenant l'heure de l'audition
devant Jean-Marie seul la police est
habilité à accréditer les croupiers
c'est un métier sous surveillance
donc je vous remets
vos cartes professionnelle et vous avez
été remise donc après une enquête
où on a rien trouvé défavorable sur vous
il est évident que si votre comportement
changeait
aussi bien à l'intérieur du casino que
sur de graves affaires à l'extérieur on
est susceptible de vous l'enlever
précaution qu'on vous demande
c'est d'éviter
d'aller jouer dans les casinos voisins
parce que bon on a eu des soucis dans un
passé récent avec des croupiers il faut
garder une certaine distance avec les
joueurs d'autant que bon c'est le jour
en question lui avait beaucoup de moyens
donc il lui arrivait donc de prêter de
l'argent
aux employés pour jouer donc on est
arrivé à certaines dérives
c'est désormais officiel ils sont de la
partie
j'étais tourne à repasser en fait
c'est un métier qui m'a jamais plu tant
que ça quoi je me cherche un peu quoi et
puis vient internet j'ai trouvé cette
formation là donc je me suis lancé la
pluie donc voilà
exit le bleu de travail Fred s'apprête à
revêtir l'uniforme du jeu d'argent
[Musique]
dans court séjour il y a le mot course
les hippodromes sont donc inclus dans le
terrain d'action des policiers du
Service celui de Deauville prestigieux
est exclusivement dédié au galopeur
mais le cheval est aussi un monde à la
grammaire particulière on y retrouve
Jean-Marie moduech et son adjoint Paul
un expert du hippisme direction la
balance rituel obligatoire le poids de
chaque jockey et minutieusement consigné
[Applaudissements]
et qui sont en train de vérifier que les
poids correspondent
à correspondent à au poids déclarer sur
le sur la liste des partants
quand ils le font avant la course et
après pour les pour ceux qui sont dans
les dans l'argent c'est surtout parce
que parce que en fonction de leur valeur
ils sont obligés de porter ce poids
c'est notamment le cas dans les courses
à handicap ou leur handicapeur essaye de
mettre tout les chevaux sur un pied
d'égalité et donc par rapport à ça il
est fixe le poids des chevaux
récemment affectés dans le service Paul
s'est d'abord fondu dans le décor pour
appréhender ce monde qui est chaponnant
initié même le directeur de l'hippodrome
amie du temps à s'intégrer c'est pas
issu du milieu
à l'époque c'était pas évident
maintenant peut-être un peu mais c'est
pas simple d'y rentrer quand même les
gens sont très méfiants
difficiles pour les policiers de
pénétrer cette société du cheval
emprunte de bourgeoisie provinciale et
de tradition rurales elle fonctionne en
vase clos c'est un microcosme le monde
des courses c'est un microcosme de c'est
un monde bien bien fermé bien à part ou
les gens les gens s'entendent bien entre
eux on va dire
[Applaudissements]
Grégory Benoît fait partie de la caste
des jockeys un cercle également très
fermé
ah c'est pas évident de faire sa place
parce que il y a quand même 700
licenciés en France donc c'est pas
évident de se faire une place dans tout
ça mais bon faut épargner aujourd'hui tu
es pro ouais je suis professionnel
actuellement on est déjà depuis six ans
je vois ça à droite à gauche quand le
service un maximum d'entraîneur pour
pouvoir avoir beaucoup de chevaux à
monter l'après-midi en course
pour la casaque est unique pastel
Grégory et son cheval Palampur son mal
parti dans ce prix du ruisseau des
houilles bloquer la corde notre favori
se tient à l'arrière garde mais il n'a
pas dit son dernier mot dans la ligne
d'arrivée le galoper fait montre de
toute sa classe et se prépare à enrhumer
ses concurrents
[Rires]
la propriétaire de Palampur voit son
poulain pleinement assumer ses
responsabilités et franchir premier la
ligne d'arrivée
pour la deuxième place Givors
mais posséder un cheval n'est pas
réservé aux véritables professionnels du
métier cela peut aussi devenir un pari
pour le simple torfiste
premier choix à l'époque c'est pareil en
France l'Afrique 42 millions après
l'investissement a été très bon parce
que des fois est conseillers puis ça se
passe pas toujours bien
un petit peu perdu oui c'est exactement
ça j'en suis à mon huitième trotteur
j'ai 58 ans
il y a un gros facteur chance c'est
comme comme le gars qui autour d'une
table de poker qui paraît qu'un 2 et 3
et puis qui a 4 5 6 au flop et voilà des
sous mais c'est pareil c'est un petit
peu la même chose ça joue à rien des
fois on va dans après on voit trois
chevaux qui vous plaisent on a G2 et le
troisième c'est celui-là qui qui a du
potentiel et qui gagne de l'argent quoi
voilà
immédiatement après une épreuve les
chevaux se rendent dans le rond pour
s'acquitter d'une autre procédure
inscrite au Code des Courses
l'identification chaque animal dispose
d'une puce implantée généralement dans
l'encolure
le 7 c'est moi
tous les chevaux sont vérifiés avant la
course avec le livret d'accompagnement
et après ainsi que la puce et on les
vérifie après la course le bon cheval
après l'identification les chevaux
arrivés dans les premières places
doivent se rendre chez le vétérinaire
pour le contrôle antidopage
mais 20 minutes après la vérification
électronique de sa puce le gagnant palam
pure reste introuvable
au prélèvement il il est suivi pendant
que le cheval s'est recouvert de la
course et ensuite et il va venir au box
de prélèvement
dans ces moments il tourne alors il
tombe ça veut dire bon ici le docteur
Alvarez semble embarrasser pour
détourner notre attention il nous montre
alors un cheval blessé et d'exciter au
hémorragie
qui est révélé
30 minutes ce délai intrigue les
policiers
[Applaudissements]
donc je sais pas ce qu'on peut faire en
une demi-heure mais bon je sais qu'ils
allaient directement du rond du rond à
la au box réservé aux vétérinaire
je comprends pas pourquoi une demi-heure
il arrive il arrive enfin palamp pure
apparaît dans l'aile des services
vétérinaires deux prélèvements seront
effectués sur le galopeur
dans le box on commence d'abord par
siffler cela un site paraît-il le cheval
à uriner plus rapidement
[Musique]
l'échantillon sera envoyé pour analyse
dans un laboratoire spécialisé
une prise de sang est parfois effectuée
mais elle n'est pas systématique
dans le milieu les cas avérés de dopage
volontaires sont statistiquement très
rares mais en matière de substance
illicite les policiers se sentent
parfois confrontés à une ambiance de loi
du silence
vous en avez c'est toujours les mêmes
qui sont ciblés par contre vous en avez
pas un pas un qui vous parlera on vous
le dit comme ça
il se plaignent il se plaignent mais
beaucoup vous disent si on parle
derrière c'est nous qui allons nous
faire injecter parce que c'est souvent
c'est les gros en plus les grosses
familles ou les gros à travers bien et
puis ben au niveau des instances
dirigeantes ceux-là ils sont un petit
peu protégés
la Basse-Normandie compte 31 hippodrome
et 16 casino pour seulement trois
policiers courts et jeux pas facile de
mener à bien les enquêtes judiciaires
pour pas l'ampur le contrôle antidopage
s'est révélé négatif
mais quand on s'attaque au monopole de
l'État les cours ces jeux peuvent mettre
le paquet 5 février 2008 perquisition
d'envergure dans les locaux d'une PME
soupçonnée de placer des machines à sous
dans les cafés c'est l'affaire
visionnelle
visionnex c'est peut-être une
microfaille dans le monopole une bonne
idée sur les bornes pour deux euros les
10 minutes on a accès Internet à chaque
fois que l'on met deux euros petit
cadeau une loterie électronique on peut
y gagner jusqu'à 100 euros
le principe a déjà séduit près de 500
établissements comme ce café situé en
périphérie de Lille un troquet populaire
tout y est vert c'est la couleur du PMU
tu rentres le 4 du rond
mais depuis peu l'orange de visionnex a
fait son apparition le patron est ravi
de sa nouvelle borne
il faut dire que c'est son salle de jeux
entre entre le PMU les Français des jeux
et qui sort maintenant donc c'est que du
c'est que du plaisir pour mes joueurs
sont
et cette clientèle de joueurs semble
davantage s'éclater avec le billard
électronique gratuit quand surfant sur
la toile
[Musique]
c'est exactement le même profil que le
bon dimanche ou en fait parce que les
mecs mettent de l'argent de l'argent une
galerie celui qui passe derrière avec
une petite pièce
de donner de l'argent cette machine
elle a pas le choix il faut tomber sur
ça quoi et avec laqué Julie Cathy me
disent toute l'après-midi ils ont
dépensé des thunes ils ont rien pris moi
je suis arrivé au soir j'avais perdu 100
€ et je le sais je vais risquer 2 €. bah
tu vois il y a une taille là qui arrive
20 20 euros sur 20 euros 20 euros sur 20
euros 20 euros sur 20 euros elle sort
avec rien du tout
au salon des cafetiers Olivier sigouanet
le PDG de visionnex présente ses
machines à toute la profession chez les
produits bistrot on est amateur de
brèves de comptoirs l'entrepreneur ne se
prive pas pour raconter sa mésaventure
judiciaire
56 heures de garde à vue Ferrero comme
Philippines
est une machine à sous ils sont venus me
chercher à l'usine à 10 ans le matin en
Normandie tout le monde en garde à vue
perquisition de l'usine qui était pas
chez moi quand c'est le diable
aujourd'hui repris des couleurs et
semble plus rassuré quant à la légalité
de son activité mais il était très
inquiet quand l'affaire a éclaté le PDG
avait même fini par douter
quand ça t'arrive tout le monde tout le
monde a un doute il y a pas simplement
que le dépositaire qui peut avoir un
doute même mon entourage familial avait
un doute mais est-ce que c'est vrai ça
fait des mois que tu nous dis que tu as
pris toutes les précautions parce qu'il
faut prendre toutes les précautions dans
ce métier mais ce qui t'arrive
aujourd'hui
c'est insensé ça paraissait insensé il y
avait une faille il y avait quelque
chose moi-même je me suis dit mais ils
ont raison
au bout de 56 heures quand on vous a dit
monsieur vous êtes un truand vous cachez
votre jeu vous abusez des gens vous avez
abusé de toutes les personnes que vous
avez rencontrées
Olivier sigonnet a-t-il trouvé la
martingale juridique pour contourner le
monopole autre question posée par ce
dossier celle de l'indépendance de la
police quand l'affaire a éclaté les
policiers ont été accusés d'avoir agi en
service commandé pour la Française des
Jeux
il n'y a jamais eu au niveau du service
central des courts séjours ou de la
sous-direction des courses et des jeux
sous son appel ancien appellation
quelqu'un fluence extérieure que ce soit
sur la diligence menée en matière de
police judiciaire comment en matière de
police administrative j'insiste
lourdement là dessus
aujourd'hui
visionnex poursuit son activité
aujourd'hui vous savez que c'est la
bataille c'est maintenant comment il
faut faire pour se rencontrer la surface
ou pas et vous avez quoi comme vous êtes
dans le département c'est combien
de microfailles apparaissent dans le
monopole mais internet a déjà ouvert la
grande brèche de multiples sites qui
sont engouffrés pour proposer leur
casino poker et paris en ligne tous
illégaux en France une déferlante de
jeux d'argent au nez à la barbe du fisc
et du monopole des opérateurs
historiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la Française des Jeux a déclaré une
guerre ouverte à cette nouvelle
génération de concurrents qui empiète
sur sa chasse gardée elle a d'ores et
déjà déposer plusieurs plaintes
là aujourd'hui nous on vit une situation
en tant que Française des jeux de
préjudice puisque on peut pas concourir
alors que cette offre illégale à
prospérer c'est vrai que les nouvelles
technologies et Internet ont amené une
concurrence à portée de clics l'ensemble
des opérateurs ou la très grande
majorité des opérateurs donc qui ne sont
pas légaux en France aujourd'hui au pair
à partir de paradis fiscaux c'est
Gibraltar c'est Malte c'est les îles
angles normandes les îles Caïmans si les
principaux opérateurs de jeux en ligne
sont immatriculés dans les confettis de
l'Union comme malt ou Gibraltar ce n'est
pas que pour des raisons fiscales c'est
aussi en vertu du droit européen le
monopole contrevient aux règles de
libre-échange de l'Union c'est la
position de la Commission européenne et
devant les menaces de poursuites la
France a cédé elle doit ouvrir son
marché
le dossier est porté par le ministre de
Budget
Eric woert il doit convaincre de
nombreux députés hostiles à la
déréglementation du marché
nous savons tous que les jeux sont dans
le domaine de prédilection de dérive de
criminalité de blanchiment de dépendance
et d'addiction or dans ces conditions ma
question est simple monsieur le ministre
vous vous êtes prononcé pour une
ouverture maîtrisée quels sont les
mesures que vous allez prendre pour
éviter la criminalité pour éviter le
blanchiment pour éviter bien évidemment
la dépendance la protection des mineurs
le juste retour d'un financement pour
les justes causes et la pérennité de la
filière hippique quels sont vos réponses
la parole est à monsieur le ministre du
budget
des comptes publics et de la fonction
publique moi j'ai confiance sur notre
capacité à pouvoir ouvrir ce secteur
nous ne l'ouvrirons que si nous n'avons
évidemment en face que les moyens de le
contrôler la plus mauvaise des
situations et la situation la plus
dangereuse et celle d'aujourd'hui
monsieur le député et nous allons bien
évidemment y mettre fin en toute
responsabilité
la loi devrait être votée d'ici 2010 une
licence permettra à l'opérateur
d'exercer en toute légalité sur le
territoire français avec publicité et
marketing mais il reste encore des
arbitrages délicats notamment la
fiscalité qui sera appliquée les
nouveaux opérateurs pourront organiser
des paris sur les courses hippiques
françaises sans craindre de poursuite le
PMU voit son confortable monopole
disparaître et le monde du cheval pour
l'instant s'y protégé s'inquiète il y a
un risque de concurrence de
délocalisation des jeux si nous ne
faisons rien il est évident que le PMU
va s'assécher et que si les jeux du PMU
s'achèchent et bien c'est toute
l'activité économique est remise en
cause on a pu constater que des états
dans lesquels ils n'ont pas à veiller à
maintenir la filière économique vous
prenez le cas de la Belgique vous prenez
le cas de l'Allemagne même de l'Italie
aujourd'hui les courses sont en train de
décliner car il n'y a pas le retour aux
professionnels
retours financier et économique aux
professionnels et toute la filière est
remise en cause
tu penses que l'ouverture va se faire
quand moi je pense ça va être en fin
d'année
parce que moi je suis dans le comité
on la sent en étant en train de
s'engager entre nous
non seulement la douche à fouetter mais
c'est qu'il y a un véritable risque et
ça verte on est parfaitement conscient
France Gallo l'une des deux sociétés qui
chapote toute la filière et le PMU a
décidé de préparer la révolution des
champs de course nommé récemment à sa
tête Hubert Monza un proche d'Eric verte
il faut là aussi appelé un chat quand
vous avez un monopole quand vous avez un
prélèvement sur les enjeux qui est
assuré par l'État et reversé la filiip
pourquoi voulez-vous sortir de ce
système vous savez que c'est un système
très protecteur on vient d'année d'année
de croisade contre les sites illégaux
que l'on considérait à juste titre on
regarde notre de notre droit comme des
comme des voleurs comme des gens qui ne
payaient pas à la filia hippique leur
odeur demain ces gens-là c'est ce que je
m'efforce de faire accepter dans cette
maison nous les aurons en face de nous
autour de la table comme des partenaires
à part entière au même titre que le PMU
puisque le monopole du PMU n'existera
plus si cette loi est votée l'arrivée
d'opérateurs étrangers semble se
préparer mais à l'abri des regards
Paris le 52 rue du Turbigo l'appartement
numéro 14 renvoie à un locataire au
patronyme plutôt énigmatique de
l'extérieur rien ne laisse présager
qu'il s'agit des locaux français
d'Unibet un géant du paris sportif et du
jeu en ligne après des années
d'opposition frontale avec l'État à
quelques encablures de l'ouverture il
s'agit de faire profil bas
on essaye d'être présent de manière
peut-être pas discrète mais en tout cas
pas de manière ostentatoire dans la
mesure où en ce moment l'état travaille
à cette ouverture de marché donc on
essaye de de composer avec cette
situation
en attendant pour Unibet l'herbe est
plus verte à Wimbledon banlieue de
Londres depuis l'Angleterre l'opérateur
suédois a entrepris son ascension
progressive dans le monde du jeu en
ligne
immatriculer à Malte l'entreprise a
installé ses équipes opérationnelles
dans le pays qui a vu naître le
bookmaking alors que les monopoles
européens sont en train de s'effondrer
c'est un moment clé pour se positionner
sur les marchés un moyen parmi d'autres
le sponsoring sportif Unibet vient de
conclure un accord avec un grand club de
foot espagnol
ce type d'opération de sponsoring est
assez cher
environ 2 millions d'euros
mais si tu opportunité pour prendre part
au négociations en tant que véritable
acteur du jeu en ligne dans l'Union
européenne
tu me manques afin de proposer nos
produits et faire du marketing
c'est à la fois une avancée politique et
économique pour nous
afin d'analyser au plus près les
championnats du monde entier
l'entreprise emploi une grande diversité
de nationalité dont un bon nombre de
Français le quotidien d'un book
déterminer la juste côte
en fonction de l'expérience des infos
qu'on peut avoir au niveau des des
plateformes des équipes des blessures
des suspensions
on fait ça aussi en fonction de quelques
statistiques
après il y a ce qui rentre en compte un
peu on va dire infini
et puis il y a l'état du marché parce
que ce qu'elle a concurrence ensuite il
y a toujours des infos dernières minutes
qui arrivent et qui font bouger le
marché en fait d'accord et donc c'est
pour ça que jour des matchs les cotes
peuvent pas mal bouger en fonction des
infos comme un marché tout simplement on
peut même miser après le début d'une
rencontre le book modifié alors les
cotes en temps réel
en direct sur de snooker pendant le
déroulement du match je change les cotes
en temps réel en fonction d'évolution du
score et du nombre de manches remportés
par chacun des joueurs
l'offre de paris est quasi illimitée on
y spécule entre autres sur les chances
de Laurence Ferrari de rester au 20
heures de TF1 ou sur le carnet rose des
têtes couronnées quid des héritiers de
la couronne du Danemark
Marie cavalier la princesse Marie
cavalier qui est française est enceinte
c'est le dernier Paris un peu fou qu'on
a conçu est-ce que ça va être un garçon
ou une fille quand est-ce qu'elle va
accoucher est-ce que ce sera une
naissance multiple le nom de l'enfant
nous avons établi une liste de prénoms
royaux traditionnels
récemment Unibet a développé son poker
une offre indispensable pour un site de
jeux en ligne mais les concepteurs sont
vigilants en décembre dernier une énorme
arnaque à 20 millions de dollars a été
révélé sur un site pourtant très
fréquenté
la structure de la compagnie était un
peu curieuse
il y avait des serveurs au Canada
apparemment les concepteurs du logiciel
n'étaient pas assez encadrés
des codes d'accès qui leur permettaient
de voir les cartes de tous les joueurs
la chose étrange c'est que les tricheurs
ne jouaient même pas intelligemment
d'une entreprise bien organisée
simplement grâce au rapport statistiques
aurait dû déceler la fraude en moins
d'une semaine
sur ces ordinateurs Unibet control le
montant et le volume des paris engagés
c'est un métier à risque
en 2008 Unibet a enregistré pour environ
675 millions d'euros en Paris en tout
genre
retour dans l'Hexagone le Stade de
France aujourd'hui ce temple du sport
est investi par une catégorie inédite de
compétiteurs les joueurs de poker c'est
la quatrième édition du France Poker
Tour un tournoi amateur dont les escales
se tiennent partout dans l'Hexagone
ce jour là en compte 1500 afficionados
il n'y a aucun endroit au monde
entière
tout semble légal et pourtant la
compétition est sponsorisée par winamax
un site de poker en ligne illégal en
France la publicité n'est également
alors ici on évite de provoquer les
autorités
seul l'équipe de joueurs professionnels
arbore les couleurs de Winamax en mai
dernier à Tours le tournoi a reçu la
visite des policiers des cours ses yeux
qui ont saisi les affiches de sponsor
du matériel publicitaire donc contre
toute bien en contre toutes raisons
juridiques puisque le Winamax est un
opérateur anglais et en application du
traité de Rome c'est winamax à droite
proposer ses services aux joueurs
français donc il est tout à fait
inadmissible aujourd'hui que les
autorités s'en prennent à un opérateur
légalement établi dans un pays de la
communauté et d'ailleurs nous avons
porté plainte contre les courses et jeux
et contre le procureur de Tours qui a
autorisé cette perquisition sur les 1500
joueurs du Stade de France une trentaine
c'est qualifié pour la grande finale qui
s'est tenue un mois plus tard mais lors
de cette ultime étape le France Poker
Tour a émigré en Italie il est interdit
en France d'intéresser la partie avec un
prix en argent d'or de casino
les tournois comme le tournoi qu'on voit
aujourd'hui le France Poker Tour ça va
des tournois sans droit d'entrée je
pense que si je dis pas de bêtises on
peut organiser des tournois gratuits et
on peut remettre des lots mais on peut
pas remettre de prix en argent on peut
pas remettre de liquide à la fin du
temps dans d'accord pourtant il y a une
notation là pourtant sur son fils la
dotation c'est pour ça que la finale va
pas être en France elle va se faire à
San Remo le moment où on va remettre de
l'argent aux joueurs
on pourrait pas on peut pas organiser ça
en France
le rôle des joueurs de l'équipe winamax
animer les tables et faire rêver les
foules Nicolas Levy fait partie de cette
première génération de professionnelle
français le job d'une star du bluff
courir les casinos du monde entier
afin de mieux populariser le poker rien
de tel que des people qui se font
totalement des Kidam comme Pierre
Bénichou ou encore Vikash doraso
il y a 1000 joueurs à Paris au Stade de
France en train de jouer au poker
c'est une vraie mode c'est un jeu très
simple à jouer assez convivial ou on
peut il y a la trait de la compétition
de l'argent des petits gains
au terme du week-end Pierre Bénichou a
pris la tête du tournoi son avance en
jetons est confortable dans le jargon
des joueurs on dit qu'il est le TIP
leader un mini événement que la presse
spécialisée s'est empressée de relater
il fait un peu araignée sa loi sur la
table depuis hier il y a apparemment
c'est un joueur de cartes un vété mais
c'est la première fois qu'il discutait
un tournoi de poker en fait il a déjà
beaucoup joué au poker format tournoi
avec des amateurs comme ça c'était la
première fois pour lui et une bonne
chose parce qu'on m'avait dit qu'il
était très mauvais perdant donc tant
qu'il gagne ça va
on le retrouve dans un duel avec Vikash
doraso dont les jetons sont comptés
l'ancien footeux annonce tapis
000 7000 7000 piles et l'emporte pour
cette fois-ci
retour en Basse-Normandie il est 10h le
casino de Trouville vient d'ouvrir ses
portes en ces temps difficiles il faut
taper le client petit dej gratuit pour
tout le monde les casinotis accusent une
baisse de 8% de leur recette on fait
tout pour attirer même le plus petit des
portes monnaie mise minimale 1 centime
d'euro c'est la machine de la crise on a
fait le test sur l'occasion de Trouville
en lançant directement 15 machines à 1
centime il y a un peu plus d'un an
maintenant et là aujourd'hui notre parc
comprend 22 machines à un centime sont
des machines ou le client aujourd'hui
pour des mises très raisonnables passent
du temps et juste en face à Deauville le
soir venu les feux du casino continuent
de briller
je vous laisserai pas quitter la salle
sans voir de jackpot a plus de 500.000
euros
quand même donc sur ces quatre machines
pour pour trois jetons de 1 euro on peut
gagner jusqu'à donc là actuellement
551000 euros
c'est un jackpot qui qui attire
évidemment énormément de monde qui se
joue uniquement avec trois pièces sur
ces quatre machines et un jour ou
l'autre un joueur va repartir avec 550
000 euros du casino et ça ça fait rêver
beaucoup beaucoup de gens je peux vous
dire mais le rêve virent parfois au
cauchemar quand sous les lumières du
casino l'argent brûle un peu trop les
doigts des flambeurs
commissariat de Caen service des courses
et jeux cet homme vient solliciter aux
autorités un interdit de jouer inscrit
dans un fichier national la mesure
assure sa mise au banc de tous les
casinos et cercles français
les bandits du Calvados ont englouti
toutes ces économies
puis après c'est bon on arrive pas à s'y
faire alors on va voir une maison de
crédit on emprunte et on emprunte et on
emprunte donc c'est une situation
infernale peut arriver au casino
après manger disons vers 21h en sortie
en faire la fermeture oui mais ça met
souvent arrivé ouais on croit toujours
qu'on va se refaire mais en fin de
compte
[Applaudissements]
je viens de perdre 500 euros
demain c'est sûr j'y vais plus j'y vais
plus ah non non demain c'est fini et
puis on est pris au jeu
soit vous ne faites rien et vous
continuez à être exclus soit vous
sollicitez donc la levée de la mesure
qui vous concerne si je mesure on fait
une petite santé bureau retournez mais
bon alors
ce que je dois quand même vous dire
c'est que effectivement
on a des gens qui demandent la levée
directement de la mesure il faut savoir
que le pourcentage de rechute est quand
même très important vous êtes interdit
de casino mais c'est vrai que il n'y a
pas
d'interdiction si vous voulez de
fréquenter
des PMU
les jeux de français des jeux
arrêté parce que ça rapporte rien si ça
rapporte à l'état mais c'est tout alors
ça il entend géolise et sans me faire
interdire
un loto mondial est annoncé pour les
prochaines années dans le Nouveau Monde
du Jeu globalisé on n'arrête pas le
progrès
[Musique]